alors c'est vraiment une manifestation
qui grandit d'année en année c'est notre
dixième édition cette année on a
commencé avec quatre restaurants 2008
et puis cette année donc comme je disais
on est à une quarantaine à peu près sûr
de ville donc c'est vraiment une belle
évolution qu'on a pu observer
c'est donc un moyen de promotion mais
c'est aussi et surtout un moyen des
changes avec les québécois et on a pu
observer de très belles créations de la
part des chefs participants
montréal a vraiment une très très grande
scène culinaire ldc public il reconnu
pour la qualité de ses restaurants la
qualité de sa cuisine
donc les montréalais et les québécois de
manière générale sont les amateurs de
bonne bouffe comme le disait si c'est
pas du tout péjoratif
donc ils sont toujours en recherche
effectivement de nouveautés de quelque
chose de coloré le fait qu'on le fasse
en septembre également ça permet un peu
de prolonger l'été dans leur assiette
donc c'est toujours très apprécié
c'est une période qui est assez
charnière pour nous en tant que
destination soleil parce que c'est le
moment où les québécois commencent à
réfléchir à leurs prochaines vacances
d'hiver
donc c'est pour nous un moyen d'avancer
la haute saison et puis de déjà
s'immiscer dans leurs esprits en se
disant pourquoi pas la martinique cette
année alors c'est la richesse
effectivement de la gastronomie la
richesse de nos produits également parce
que même si on est au québec mais on
utilise effectivement pas mal de
produits que l'on retrouve un peu
partout
donc c'est vraiment indiqué aux
visiteurs potentiels que la martinique
c'est bien plus que juste le colombo où
le ti punch ou beaucoup des pistes qui
piquent en bouche c'est vraiment
différentes saveurs différentes textures
différentes couleurs et c'est ce qu'on
essaie de montrer chaque année